so what's up guys good to be here
i just did the kill tony yesterday
it was a great time
learned a lot about myself learned a lot
about the guest who's very funny
uh he's really great in the moment and
really
great at riffing
uh
so that was fun killed tony last night
um
[Music]
i'm watching succession i think it's a
pretty good show
um
i uh
oh you know i could just turn up the
volume
i love doing these because it's like fun
to mess around with technology and get
it right
um so it's part tinkering and part art
because
i'm also just like
doing a broadcast where i'm going out to
people
so that's
fun um
i think it's weird how
a lot of people
don't
have sex with me
um yesterday i didn't have sex with
anyone
[Music]
i did
touch a couple butts
um
i touched one but consensually
last night
and i also
um
i also kissed
four girls last night so that was pretty
cool
what happened this week when you were on
killtone you must have been your worst
showing in a while
okay yeah so that guy says that
i can't stop drinking 99 peanut butter
whiskey
are you talking about
what's that thing
whiskey pig or sweet water or something
uh yeah i got really small eyes
uh i'm not high right now i was high
yesterday i'm completely sober i did a
lot of uh
um
i did a lot of drugs yesterday i did an
edible i smoked a couple joints i think
yeah i did i sometimes forget
um
uh
i don't know if i need any other drugs
um but yeah last week two weeks ago is
when i actually filmed the episode where
i'm a guest
so you guys are looking at a past me i
already went through
the profound deep sense of regret and
embarrassment from my showing
two weeks ago
uh this one girl was like you're not
good at comedy you're not good at buck
hunter what are you good at so that was
kind of
very
offensive to me
so i've already been hurt by that
also i think i got a little too drunk
also i was asked to be the guest like
30 minutes before the show so maybe i
wasn't in the right mindset but honestly
i think it was just because i was like
i was trying too hard i think i was just
like oh i got something funny to say hey
look guys i'm trying to be funny
look at me i'm a comedian look at how
funny i'm being
um
yeah but some people said good show last
week and all that
uh i'm not high right now
everyone thinks i'm always high so it's
good when i'm actually high but i've
been high very seldomly on these
podcasts
on these live casts how you hang that
picture on a vandal i'm actually in an
apartment i got a van i got an apartment
from a friend who isn't using the
apartment anymore she let me stay here
she happens to be a woman
that's a part of my life
is women giving me stuff
so that's pretty cool
um
and uh yeah i mean i think i got a
little too drunk
last time i did the the guesting i wish
i was a little more sober
uh instead i'm sober on these live
podcasts so you are getting the best me
i wish i could have done that for my
whatever
um
where are the bodies hans
i am not a murderer i think murder is a
not that fun of a hobby and also very
dangerous
um
but yeah i mean i had a fun time i had
the best seat in the house i got to see
jared nathan become famous
so it was a pretty fun episode
took edible yesterday 100 sober i mean i
think so i think that i'm pretty sober
um
you know how can i help
uh that i get weed out of my system real
quick or maybe it just stays in there
for a long time and i'm high a lot
but yeah i'm having a good time uh i'm
enjoying life uh jerry nathan is nice he
beat me at connect four and he's
mentally handicapped so it made me feel
a little mentally handicapped but i
think he played before i think he's like
he he knows how to play and maybe he's
like a savant he's like good at
good at that [ __ ]
um
yeah i mean i don't think i'm high right
now if i was i might be a little happier
i am house-sitting
i'm not gonna replace the freezer food i
don't think that she's coming back i
don't know exactly what's happening but
i think that i'm free to eat all the
food in here
she had some clam chowder that i ate and
if she
wants it back i'll definitely pay for it
but i don't want it just to sit there
and you know at least i'm uh using it at
least someone's using it it's good that
i can uh help out by eating all our food
and staying in our house rent free i'm
really helping her out i'm a real good
friend for
staying in her house for free
um
i think i did better the first time i
think the second time that i was on kill
tony as a guest i was just like
hey guys what about comedy
um
i uh
i am monetized again so that's good so
that's fun uh but yeah i mean i think
that uh
i had some stuff to say what i would
change if i ever got to be a guest again
i would just uh
[ __ ]
uh
be real calm and chill and just say
things when it's easy and not like force
it out i would just like be like oh this
is just like what i'm thinking and it
just happens to come out and oh look it
just happens to be funny because if it's
if it's effortless it's more funny than
if i'm like trying really hard to be
funny so i think that's what was wrong
with my
episode that came out yesterday but
um i hope that i could stay out of the
way and jared nathan had a great set uh
christina mariani had a great set a lot
of great sets happened so i'm glad that
i could be there for that and i didn't
get in the way too much of stuff like
that
i let the show happen around me
do you believe mongolians have souls
yeah i mean
they're pretty much just horses
mongolians are just an extension of a
horse they think like a horse they walk
like a horse
they're uh they're basically horse
people
um but yeah i
i love
that i'm monetized again
that's fun uh i sent them an expired id
and they just were like yeah this looks
right
let's uh
pass this guy
i have tried hitting on christina
mariani
that process is currently ongoing
i introduce memberships into my youtube
so you guys can buy like memberships and
get special emojis
there's a van emoji there's a [ __ ]
eyed emoji there's a capitalism emoji so
if you want to buy a membership you get
that and also you get like i put up a
couple of videos
that i'm going to release later of like
me just kissing people compilation so
it's just kiss after kiss after kiss so
if you want to jerk off to that you can
buy a membership and get it early
or there was another video about my soap
joke and my african water joke
and
my child molester joke so i just got
that all subtitled up
and i'm trying to i'm going to try to
make it a vertical video
which is going to be tricky because i
got adobe premiere
and uh i need to make it vertical which
is a pain to ask and then the subtitles
have to change how big they are
uh huh you have any jokes about cheese
uh cheese
no
cheese is so cheesy i don't like to make
cheesy jokes
um
i uh
what's the best way to do dmt
uh i would say ayahuasca in the woods
with a ecuadorian shaman
and the jungle noises in the background
when's the next catan cast i'll try to
get one tonight
uh if i can get enough people to come
over i'd love to do a katan cast
um i love that uh people play and that
we can talk but katana is sort of weird
because when you're playing you gotta
like okay is it your turn okay stop
talking for a second it's her turn uh do
you have any sheep and then conversation
is ruined
by the this noise of uh clerical work of
katanning but then it's also good
because it's like background noise so
that you break the silence
that there you don't have to break the
silence if you have something stupid you
want to say
and it's gonna be the first thing anyone
said in five minutes it's harder to say
as opposed to someone was just like does
anyone have any sheep then it's easier
to be like my butthole's itchy
so it just gets the conversation started
but it also limits it at the same time
so katana is fun
it's a board game you get to look at
people in the eye
and i last time i whipped everyone's ass
so i don't know if it's ethical for me
to just keep inviting people over to
whoop their asses and humiliate them in
front of
thousands of viewers so
if they want to come um i'd love to have
them
hans do you have a korean girlfriend do
you have korean korean friends
i actually don't have any korean friends
i mostly hang out with comedians
uh the only way i can make korean
friends is if i went to a korean church
and i worshiped the lord with them and
then i could be like hey by the way
you
want to play katan or go to a comedy
show um
um
so i would say that i don't have any
korean friends
uh
yeah i think that korean friends would
be great to have because we have so much
in common i don't have to like explain
anything we have a common background and
uh that's pretty cool
um what do you think is more important
podcasting or live shows i would say
live shows for now
um i'm not really a podcaster i would
say i'm more of a comedian
i did grow up christian as an asian
person koreans have a lot of a christian
christianity in it because we love
everything american
we love it so much we just want to be
americans
um
the next podcast probably not for a
while unless i can get them in here i'm
really not trying to go out this is so
much more convenient if i go out to do a
podcast that's 30 minutes there
uh podcast and 30 minutes back so that's
like an hour extra and here i can just
do it i save an hour
and
i enjoy doing like twice the amount of
talking that i normally do
but yeah i'm sorry if i sounded a little
arrogant when i was saying that i kicked
everyone's asses at katan
um i mean but it's on video i kind of
did
so
that's kind of cool that i did that
but i don't want to be good at katan i
want to be good at
uh making friends and if that's
uh gonna get in the way of making fruits
then it's not really worth it to win a
katan
what's the best way to support me
um probably by
lifting me up using your
ass and glutes
uh i would say maybe your thighs use
your abs maybe your abs should be
tight and uh stabilizing your spine i
would say the best way to support me is
probably with a venmo that way you don't
have to
give thirty percent to youtube.com they
already have enough money
uh i'm on venmo hans kim comedy but i
mean
that's not like the most important thing
i'm the
i mean it'd be nice to get money i'd
probably get a sponsorship i think that
might help
[Music]
but yeah i mean
whatever money money's cool
um
so
yeah
last episode of other people has no
audio too bad i know
i think the problem is that the zoom
wasn't plugged in all the way it was
just like dangling it was a dangling
chad
so
uh even if i uh
did have it plugged in we only could
pick up a certain number of mics we only
could pick up two out of the four mics
so it would have been two out of the
four mics
it would have been uh not ideal but it's
better than no audio right
uh i did get some t-shirts made there
my name hans but it looks like the vans
logo because it's like three out of the
four letters are the same i do work out
uh this is a an apartment i'm not in the
van anymore let's check the description
uh the description will have the
fact that i'm living in an apartment
it's not like i love living in cars i
live in a car because it's cheap not
because i love carburetors and the smell
of gasoline if i could have a home for
free i would live in a home and i do
have a home for free so i'm living in a
home so
it's all about economic freedom it's
about
[Music]
living the lifestyle that i want and
being adaptable and flexible
instead of being rigid and being like no
i only live one way i'm an organic being
and i can change whatever setting that i
live in i can live in a lot of different
situations
i mean i'm at the bottom of the spectrum
in the van so everything is up from here
so i'm very flexible and with
flexibility comes uh
you know like cool perks that i wouldn't
have had if i lived in a home then i'd
be like i already have a home i can't be
house it so this is this is cool that i
get to live in a house and that i don't
live in a van you know you should uh be
happy that i'm out of the van
unless you want me in a van uh so that
you can watch me suffer and take
perverse joy out of watching me pee in a
bucket
and [ __ ] in a can
um
i uh
did you or joe rogan home come with that
painting
did you
joe roganovsky ever think about
upgrading vans
um i mean my van is already pretty sick
i don't think i would get another van i
think i'd get a home i think i'd upgrade
the van to a home but in terms of uh
in terms of [ __ ]
uh
in terms of [ __ ] vans i mean how much
better could i get i mean i could get a
better like
drivable vehicle but in terms i have a
high top roof
it's 144 inch wheelbase which is smaller
than the 177 inch the 144 is good
because it's smaller and i don't need
that extra 30 inches of space 33 inches
i think i'm good with
144 compact is good you can fit into
more spaces
uh it's harder it's more fuel efficient
i love i think it's a perfect size
the van is uh perfect for me
uh so no i think i don't think i would
upgrade the van i think the van is good
the way it is
um
i got a bed i got a kitchen i really
need to do a [ __ ]
van tour of that thing
has anything sketchy happened with the
van life
um i ran out of battery juice in the
middle of the desert
that was crazy i had to wait for someone
to come by and give me a jump
but luckily it came right away and it
took a while for the thing to charge up
and it's like if he wasn't there and
willing to spend that much time
then i would have been [ __ ]
but it started and i think it's because
i turned on a bunch of lights the day
before using an inverter and i don't
think that the
uh splitter that they had for the car
battery versus my leisure battery was
very good and i think it leaked over and
it used the car battery to power the
[ __ ]
it hasn't happened since the battery
hasn't gone out since so
i think it's good
um would you live in a cyber truck
i think they're not as good as a
sprinter van they're more fuel efficient
but a cyber truck doesn't have the high
top roof
um
what music do i like alternative i like
other stuff how often do you get high
probably every other day now i used to
get high every day but i have a little
throat issue
i'm a little [ __ ] i'm a little [ __ ] my
little bitch-ass throw can't handle
blunts to the face
so
um
i stopped smoking as much
um
i uh
huh
yeah i have this little bong i have the
silicon bong that i use which is pretty
dope
uh looks like a dildo but it doesn't
break right now my friend riley's using
it because i'm trying not to smoke so
i'm like here take it so that i don't
smoke
um
i have a portable jump box but it's like
hard to hold a lot of charge but yeah i
mean i haven't needed a jump in a while
i have like one of those little handles
and is this big and it's heavy-ish [ __ ]
i need to charge it
blunts are great when you're 14 or if
you're a snoop dogg are you calling
snoop dogg 14 that's kind of rude
um
yeah i mean i think marijuana is like a
a drug and a lot of people self-medicate
with it because capitalism is depressing
or american modern life
modern society is depressing we don't
have any spiritual purpose
or a myth that defines us
back in the day at least you could be
like oh i love god and i love britannia
but nowadays there's nothing we're in
nihilistic culture so our self
indulgence and hedonistic pleasures
take place
of any deeper meaning and a great way to
feel good is with feel good drugs by
injecting dopamine into your head
so
wheat is good weed distracts you from
the hopelessness of our society and our
culture
and it gives you the positive emotions
that should come from other things that
are missing right now and it's like a
stop gap
until you get all the other things that
you're looking for
it keeps your brain healthy and keeps it
from deteriorating into sadness
um
capitalism is depressing more kami talk
is that the same guy that's been talking
mad [ __ ] about communism
how much you smoke to figure that out
um probably a helpful dose of acid and
mushrooms
uh
help me see what was happening but it
was instinctive i think we all
gravitate towards weed because we find
our normal day-to-day life lacking and
we need to supplement
our dopamine and endorphins with
exogenous chemicals
uh
who is your comedy inspirations my
comment comedic inspirations joe rogan
number one he's the reason i started i
think his comedy is very insightful and
it tackles subjects that are large and
are
the inevitable conclusion of dick jokes
he talks about the future and human
nature
um
i think that joe rogan is very
inspirational steve martin was doing
meta comedy before comedy even took off
um
mushrooms the only thing the good same
society
i mean mushrooms are gonna be used by
people and people are gonna save society
we have the power we are the people that
exist in physical reality in 2021 and we
can change the physical reality of our
time
if we have enough mass
cohesion so if we can
gather together and [ __ ] figure it
out we can rescue ourselves
um
i think that uh weed smoke is great
uh was uh joe rogan is a capitalist
i mean he owns a piece of capital now he
owns a comedy club that will be opening
soon somewhere sometime
uh hopefully soon hopefully close by i
can't wait
but he is a capitalist i guess but he's
also a worker laborer who has become
wildly successful
and i think that joe rogan's success
should be replicated all over
and that we should all have a piece of
that kind of success
[Music]
i think that he is a worker that got his
[ __ ] together and figured it out and
became unbelievable
and
he
fights for the rights of the working
class
and
i think he's a very inspirational figure
in terms of
a proletariat that made it through hard
work he's meritocracy in action
and he didn't do it through the common
avenues
of signing up for a cubicle job and
working really hard he spoke directly to
the people
um
i think
that's
uh what you have to do you can't play
within the rules because the rules are
corrupt and then they'll make you work
for
too long
for [ __ ]
uh you gotta talk directly to the people
the people are
uh more important than like
the money the money will follow if you
lead the people and joe rogan talk to
the people and
people
is
awesome
people is better than uh
the entrenched powers
of capital and money
um
[Music]
so i think capitalism is when
uh people who own capital
called capitalists have rules bent in
their favor and it's like
you don't need to bend the rules in the
favor of capitalists they already have
all the money they have all the power
you're going to give them more power
most people are not capitalists they
don't have a deed to a factory they
don't own means of production they're
workers and if you don't take care of
your workers then most of your society
is going to be [ __ ] so you should take
care of your workers
because then
most of your country will be happy
uh i love rogan i'm not high at all i'm
32.
uh
sorry you had to watch an ad
if only there was a
app or a
an extension in google chrome or firefox
that could prevent you from seeing apps
from from seeing ads
if we could call it an ad blocker and
maybe we could add some extra feature
and call it adblock plus
i i recommend you download it if you're
watching ads in 2021 it means that you
[ __ ] up and you need to
do more hacking research
i'm not high right now
thank you for asking
um
i
am not high ever for these
uh it's crazy i just
this is how i normally am
so that's crazy
um i'm not asian i can't do ad blocker
it's really easy to figure out you just
have to download it and then it does
everything else
can you do some ads right now sure hey
welcome to ads of whatever
the first ad is for communism give it a
shot because the people who hate it are
the ones that ruin this country and the
world
uh the cia doesn't think it'll work uh
but
they're the ones that killed kennedy
uh join the channel to watch fun
then do uh how do you get on with those
guys
i get on is that uh get on stage with
those guys or is this a british
euphemism
for how do i get along with
lucas david lucas and william montgomery
william montgomery i see more david
lucas comes in every now and then
um
[Music]
uh
david lucas is really cool with me he
doesn't roast me even though i know he
can so i'm just going to try to keep it
that way so that he doesn't say hurtful
things about how small my eyes are or
how long my face is or
how
i am too skinny or something
uh and william montgomery is so nice and
he's just so goofy and he's so
like
uh in his own world that it's just like
so great that i could be around
um
thank you for saying that my last
podcast was unique david lachter
uh
i had a good time doing it it's just
like me hanging out with my friends and
i'm gonna do that anyways so if i film
it like and people like it then all the
better for that that's all the better
for me what do you think about the
increase of roundabouts in rural america
i think it's great i think uh if you
have straight intersections it's more
dangerous because you got cars
going like this
they're more likely to crash into each
other so if you put a little circle in
the middle
it uh do it slows everything down to an
acceptable speed and also when you're in
the middle of a stop light
and it's you're in the middle of nowhere
and it's just like red light and there's
no one coming for miles it's a waste of
time
uh so i think the roundabout is good
because then people can figure it out on
their own you don't need a light to tell
people what to do people can figure it
out and it just sort of figures it out
uh roundabouts are very communist i mean
what is communism to you
uh i guess communism is whenever you
have uh equal rights as a work as a
worker
um
i think that
it's great that
things are
great
um
what
is going on
roundabouts are pretty cool
um
so
communism
is at was you watching me watch ads
um
redistribution of wealth by force
um
i mean
why don't we just set different rules up
so like you can keep whatever wealth you
have but from now on you gotta pay
people differently
whatever you want to
figure it out
uh
to the got girl game of thrones girl
would you be excited or
afraid to be featured on red bar
i would love to be featured on red bar
um
it's not in my van
uh
[Music]
i think that red bar would be awesome
uh
what's the music scene like in austin
i put will naughty and not lie on
timeout again
uh what do you think of ted kaczynski
um
i think that
uh
which mcdonald's bathroom is this
streaming from this is actually in a
house i live in a house right now
acid tool zero really hates communism
i appreciate your
very steadfast approval of capitalism
and i think it's great that you love
billionaires so much
will you become the asian gary ridgeway
i don't want i don't like murdering
people
um
i uh i think
murder is
such a stupid way to connect with people
i think there's a lot better ways to
connect with people that are more
efficient
hey
why does d madness pee too much
um i'm sure he has some health issues
or maybe he just likes
to go around and
um
pee around a lot
i mean just because someone is rich
doesn't mean that there
uh deserve to be not criticized we
should criticize everyone and not just
just because i criticize rich people
doesn't mean i'm jealous like
sometimes rich people do something wrong
uh that doesn't mean that uh
i'm jealous of them sometimes it means
they did something wrong
and yeah i mean i think we all do some
things wrong sometimes and this isn't a
very stable system
who's the best south korean of all times
probably
um
the president once
um hans have you seen jerry nathan's
gofundme it's going off after that show
aired also
did
miss china make it back to the van or
what i think she's married i wish i
wasn't so mean to her i honestly could
understand what she was saying some of
the time
um
and uh yeah i mean
she started off her set by telling me to
hold her bag and watch her drink which
is like
not a great way to start the set but i
think she's very funny in her own way
and uh i think that
if you watch your set like
it's better than uh
what uh
what
uh she did on the show on kill tony
uh
why not hans kim i don't know what
hemphead is referring to
you hang out with rich people i do hang
out with some rich people i love hanging
out with rich people because that means
i'm getting more successful just make
fun of them and the people who like them
pretending to believe like them funny
like who's the best african of all time
yeah i mean who are you asking me who
the best south korean is
uh the best african of all time is
probably
desmond tutu
and the final episode i haven't watched
it yet i mean i'm kind of getting bored
of succession but
i'm already like so invested in it i'm
like watching all of it so it's just fun
crony capitalist puppet yeah i mean i
don't know that much about korean
history so you're probably right he's a
crony capitalist puff bit
i think he's a little conservative
hanging out with rich people is cool
because they got the best [ __ ] to steal
i'm not stealing from tony and i'm not
stealing from
joe rogan so
i think i'm good on that hanzo so drunk
last night i killed tony and too touchy
can you please forgive me
oh i don't remember that
oh yeah i mean there are a lot of hot
girls around
so i can imagine that uh it's really hot
to be around so many girls so that's
pretty cool
um
desmond tutu is like a pastor who's like
very pro african
liberation
uh what do you think about dogecoin i
think dogecoin is pretty dope uh i hope
that one of these
uh
coins takes off and that we can
actually use
cryptocurrencies instead of just betting
on which one is going to be more famous
i do miss seattle
yeah
there's sound right now i mean if i'm
doing it on my own i know how to do
sound but if i'm using their sound board
and their mics then they kind of have to
do the sound on their end and they
haven't really been shown up
so it's been kind of annoying
there's only so much i can do i mean i
can just do the sound from the recorder
from my zoom but that's not ideal i want
to get it directly from the sound board
and it just takes so much work and only
two of the mics ever show up through the
sound board so it's just like i have to
figure it out i have to figure out other
people
um
but yeah i mean eventually we'll figure
it out i'm sure because the first
episode we did it and it worked so i'm
going to try to figure it out
by next episode and hopefully i do but
if not at the very last least we're
going to have the
zoom recorded through the the mic that
it has
which isn't as good as getting it from
directly from
the
um
the soundboard
it's gonna accept doge for more merch
that's cool
i just want to have a currency that
isn't controlled by
the powers that be
pak chong he
someone said something about pak chong
he
uh
i've i don't see it
um
what's the coolest way you've been hit
on
um probably
by walking up on stage and kissing me in
terms of stormy
and rosalie and all the hot hotties
um i really love
uh stormy and women and i think it's
like great that
we have a way to communicate with each
other because i feel like if i was just
a normal person and i was trying to talk
to stormi that i would appear autistic
and
i'd be like too clingy and weird but now
that i'm on a show
and uh
she's been on it on the show with me
that it sort of is more like an ice
breaker and i can just be myself and
it's great because i love
uh to talk to women as much as they'll
let me
so hopefully they let me talk to them
because uh sometimes i just like staring
at their faces
um
when the rich can buy up and affect
market value of any crypto do you love
extreme gagging i don't love extreme
gagging i hate gagging myself so i would
hate to do it to other people
i want to extreme gag you
um crypto is controlled and more
effectively controlled by the elite cia
you look like the guy who busted me at
the
world series of poker
main event day one so no big if it was i
don't actually play poker it's probably
some other asian guy with a big head
but i love the idea of poker
and i love that it should be like
a game of skill i don't think it
necessarily is but
i think the kissing bit stopped because
not enough people really wanted to kiss
me on stage um i think after some
certain point it's like
uh
it's
i don't think girls really are desperate
to kiss people uh
so i also don't know if they want to be
on stage so whatever
i think that maybe if we go on the road
people want to kiss me more but like
here
it's just like they they live here and
i'm i live here so maybe they think it's
weird that i'm gonna try to hit on them
or something
um
kissing stopped about episode whatever i
did 10 or 15
kiss kissing episodes have you ever
heard of the donkey punch yeah isn't it
where you come in their eyes and
punch them in the face or something
something weird some white people doing
sleepover [ __ ] that's what a donkey
punch is
uh doing weird things with girls that
are embarrassing and painful and
shameful and weird
um but yeah i mean who doesn't love a
little
white dude out of sleep over energy
some girls really like that they like to
be defiled and like
embarrassed so like if you're into that
i would totally find a find a dude who's
like
got that white dude on a frat party
energy who are some of your favorite
comedians joe rogan steve martin mitch
hedberg mitch hedberg is probably one of
my favorites
um
google max hardcore
um
you since
you senshin
the great pak chung hee in that order
yi sun shin ishin
is a guy that defended korea against
japanese he built the turtle boats which
is like a normal boat with a cover on it
uh so that helped with the boarding and
uh
i think they used arrows
in lor and age of empires the turtle
boats used cannons but i think it was
actually arrows and the people are
defended inside i think he was like
looking at naval battles and been like
man i'm getting tired of being shot on
the boat what if we had
a goddamn
shield that's permanent
uh
i'm sorry that you think my tastes suck
but mitch hedberg is one of the best
um
age of empires i don't know which one
probably the older one
would you start a gaming stream i tried
gaming but it didn't work
and plus i'd have to unplug the zoom
i
i love mark normand
i love others
um
i think it's really great
to play games i think games are
a great way to learn and get better
uh in a world where you don't have any
uh
danger so you can experiment and stuff
like that
i feel
like
uh
sejong
i think that's how you say it
is a guy that's uh
i think that he's great at
coming up with the language that korean
is written in right now
um
i would love i would drink sergio if it
was free
do you like the kumtown podcast yes it's
a comedy podcast i know what come town
is uh come town's great
nick mullen is a genius stavros has good
energy and he's always laughing and he's
great riffer and then adam
is like great at being the butt of jokes
and like saying ridiculous things that
people make fun of him for
um
uh you know what kill tony is coming to
swansea mess
isn't that where they do it in some
giant banquet hall
and is those episodes were really fun
yeah mr pibb extra we all heard your
tiny little asian eyes joke you could
blanket a family of five in the arctic
with hanza's eyelids
yes i have very hooded eyelids they're
very very warm right now i'm
my eyes are constantly in a sauna
my eyes are so warm and it's better for
me to see in winter time
thoughts on the kyle rittenhouse case i
think that he's guilty of manslaughter
uh if you go to a place that's highly
charged and
provoke people
with your presence and you have to kill
them
uh then i think that uh
you
are guilty of provoking them
and that you gotta
not show up to a protest with a gun just
because
you don't like what they're protesting
or because you don't like to see
property destruction i don't think
that's a good enough excuse to just
stand around with a gun
um
and i think that the only person that
was in danger of getting killed that
night where all the people that kylo ren
house saw no one else was murdered that
night besides
uh the people that kyle reinhaus killed
he was not necessary
i would rather have 700 broken burnt
down buildings and cars and two dead
people
so he did more damage
than uh
he did more damage than he prevented
um uh so yeah i mean
don't uh don't go to a protest and uh
piss people off
and then resort to killing them
um but yeah i mean it's tricky situation
because he was attacked and he was
firing back in what he thought was
self-defense so it's like
who knows
um
how many kisses would a written house
get uh he would probably get a lot of
kisses from overweight redneck
housewives
um
don't attack a dude with a gun with guns
yourself lol i mean no one attacked him
with a gun someone pulled out a handgun
and then he got shot in the arm but he
thought it was an active shooter uh
and uh yeah i mean there was nothing
that was more dangerous that night than
kyle rattenhouse he was the one that
killed people property destruction is
not that big a deal
um
i think that lives are more important
than property
and he ruined two lives for what it's
like he he didn't even save that many
parking
lots uh
someone fired in the air and they turned
around and shot
another person that didn't fire in there
i don't think you looked into the
details you're smarter than that
i mean we all have different opinions i
just don't think that uh his intentions
were pure to show up at a protest for
black lives and uh have a gun and be
like
don't don't [ __ ] up don't [ __ ] up
protesting
don't make it a riot or else i'll shoot
you i don't think that's a good thing to
do uh that big deal he was there to help
how ignorant can one man be he was there
to help you don't need a child helping
you manage a crowd police
the police that you love so much should
have been police in the crowd if you
show up at a roller coaster as a 17 year
old kid and be like i'll help you run
the roller coaster and then three people
die two people die then uh
yeah it's uh
it's [ __ ] up you shouldn't have been
trying to do crowd control when you have
no
uh you have no ability to you have you
have been trained in crowd control let
the police do it
uh the police didn't kill anyone that
night kyle rittenhouse killed two people
i would say
avoid killing people in
in
crowd control situations so people
shouldn't call the cops when their
businesses are being looted because the
cops might kill people and you said
you'd rather lose businesses and lives
no you should call the police you
shouldn't call kyle rittenhouse
uh you should uh let the professionals
handle it because crowd control is not
always easy and children should not be
in charge of it
uh you're not gonna step off this hill
huh
are they turning into that's how did he
plan it brain dead take raffle you mean
the police that blm wants to defund
should protect yeah i mean they should
protect and not murder
innocent civilians police have a role
and just because you don't like
how they
kill black people
doesn't mean that police shouldn't exist
in general there is a role for police
it's just like
not being a authoritarian you know like
follow my orders or you're gonna die
kind of thing
um
i'm sure that a lot of you guys don't
agree with me
um
but that's fine you know this is my
opinion i don't know if i should change
it because everyone else disagrees with
me but i just
it's just not a good luck for people
that
to die
maybe peng dang has a different take
thank god you're a comedian not a lawyer
if nothing to do with race with them
hans is white privilege i am pretty
white
uh
i love being white passing i'm pretty
much the closest thing to white without
being white
jews are white some of them are white
i don't care what you are ethnically
you're white
uh unless you're like ashkenazi then
you're ashkenazi
uh but yeah i'm asian so i'm pretty
white
you're a child if you resort to personal
attacks on someone's opinion
yeah david your opinion is a poopy take
and you bet your butthole's really dirty
uh
uh you wake up with the rest of the
world all good i realize they're worth
more than property last simple intent is
everything
is an american label to put on people
uh it's pretty asian label too uh
pegging uh
is what we call white people
uh
jeffrey epstein
so i mean it's like really suspicious
because there was no cameras
uh
um
i think uh
i know david i was just kidding i was
doing like a bit about like
how i'm taking i'm i'm personally
attacking your
your opinion you said it's uh stupid to
personally attack people
uh for their opinion so i'd personally
attacked you for your opinion to be like
a funny person and hypocritical fuzzy
kill g asians and middle easterns
get white privilege so white people can
convince themselves they're not racist
uh
have you ever considered being a
baseball empire not really
uh i'd rather not watch people play
sports i'd rather play sports myself i
think
it's good to be a supporting cast some
people are good at being supporting cast
but
i'd rather be the star
and that's why i'm on stage alone
uh what are some ideas you have for kill
tony next week i have some ideas about
doing a joke about the bible
and how
it's written and judging it as a book
i have some ideas about doing jokes
about how women need to have more sex
because there's not enough sex going on
in the world
uh
i know ball player how do you know
baseball players come in all shapes and
sizes i could be like 600 pounds over
earth 60 pounds overweight and still be
a baseball player
baseball is an interesting skill i need
a bigger forearm if i want to be a
baseball player
what's your sitcom's name
succumbs are such an old way of gaining
success in comedy that's the seinfeld
method
uh i think that it's not always the best
avenue to express your comedy in i think
sitcoms are good if you have like a
whole world building thing like you see
the world in like a very
uh
very
uh
whole world like i got all the answers
type thing you're better at being broad
than deep
but i think that uh in terms of the
modern comedy game podcasting seems to
be the way to go
um
comedians i think are naturally good
podcasters because they have to
talk to a lot of people they have to get
to know a bunch of different people and
they have to be constantly improving and
changing who they are to be better to be
able to talk to society and actors they
just have to read lines they don't
actually have to talk to people they
just read lines and have the emotions
that they're told to have
sports athletes
they're not good at talking they're good
at throwing and using their body which
isn't doesn't translate to podcasting
and the musicians they're all in their
fields they're just like what what do i
feel like oh i feel like this oh you
guys feel this man oh look at this
emotion
i feel like this
and then like that's not logical and
it's harder to convey through
words what you want to say and with
comedians we're using words all the time
to express ourselves so i think
comedians are just naturally good at
comedy and plus we're out every night
talking to people and getting better as
people and learning how to
um
learning how to express ourselves so i
think comedians are natural podcasters
podcasters are good sitcoms i think are
good if you have the capital
sitcoms are expensive
and they take a lot of time and you have
to do it a certain way and
everyone who does sitcoms is like in the
system so you need to learn from someone
in the system and the system has been
uh co-opted
um where do you see yourself in 10 years
i see myself
just doing this
hopefully to a bigger audience full of
people who are actually
uh
happy for me and sort of
support me instead of saying things like
able fable haven't laughed once well you
know it's like joe rogan's podcast you
don't necessarily fall out loud and yet
it's one of the more popular podcasts so
i'm actually happy that
uh it's not one of these weird uh you
know hahaha podcast it's more of a
thinker podcast
uh but maybe i could give you something
nice to think about thank you for curing
sexual shame
christopher ryan would be proud i don't
know how i cured sexual shame
i'm trying to sexually shame women into
[ __ ] more i think that
it'd be awesome if there was more sex in
the pool and then we could spread sex
out evenly i'm working on this joke
about sex that i am excited to try out i
don't want to do it here
uh you're gonna have to tune in to kill
tony for that make us laugh comedian man
what about rogan's podcast he doesn't
make someone laugh like all crazy but
he's still a good podcaster so that's
what i'm trying to do
are you a democrat or republican i would
say i lean democratic but i think the
democratic party is too republican i'm
far left uh i would say that the
democrat and republicans are too far
right
so yeah i mean you asked i answered uh
sorry if you disagree with me but
hopefully we can still get along by
watching girls make out with me bro
you're gonna have a cult following one
day i hope so
uh bring hot all right
oh my god
uh
your podcast would be like npr hello and
welcome to hans podcast tonight on the
podcast
we're going to talk about tea and the
nice
kind of
nice energies that you can have with tea
rogan do taekwondo hans does what
i do starcraft 2.
uh i do
i'm like a shittier joe rogan i don't
really do taekwondo i did basketball i
love playing basketball
and i think basketball is a good art
form
but you have to follow the rules and
there's like a lot of rules in
basketball and it's hard to like enforce
them
if they make major league the movie
would you like to play the token asian
player hi
i will play bisbee with you
i love you
so much
um should reach out to bobby and cheetos
oh yeah i'll just reach out to them and
then i'll be on their podcast and i'll
be their best best friend it's weird
because like i don't want to just like
be like hey
i'm here and so you should be my friend
now
um
sex and communism
i mean i think like uh girls in soviet
russia were having more sex than girls
in capitalist america because they had
health care figured out
uh and then
hopefully they don't have to [ __ ]
work
their ass off when they're 70 just to
survive
um
sex and communism it's a shame that get
them away from each other like us guys
again one of the best oh thank you
um
you laugh all the time during rogan okay
well
i don't and i still love the podcast
um
free money for me democrat i worked for
it ironed it give me my [ __ ] money
i think
william montgomery and david lucas are
both funny matt and shane's secret
podcast kill tony come down great
podcast
uh can i keep you production wise go to
the next level i got all the knowledge
about that and shoot music videos so now
keep going man okay let me know what i
can do i'll do whatever i can
um
this is the far left where's the big guy
that russ tony been he's on the episode
coming out in two weeks
uh anarcho-capitalism is a way just run
that place like apple or ibm who's
funnier uh
do you have eyes
are you democrat hans no say i am bernie
sanders supporter
remember that you're right we can go
again making out with chicks
i do love tennis
uh i'm not that good at it
have you ever read the gulag archipelago
not yet
um
uh chicks i want to have more chicks on
this podcast but i honestly don't know
if chicks would be a good thing i feel
like a lot of the stuff that i say
around chicks is [ __ ] and fakery and
trickery to try to get them to sleep
with me and i don't know if that'll be
interesting on a podcast
i'd rather have like an honest
conversation with someone or i could be
authentic instead of changing who i am
to be a version of someone that i think
will get laid
do your walk do walk or run
i kick in a walk and i run around
whenever i can
uh
what are my great ideas that i should
convince joe rogan of that i should be
able to work out in his gym and live
there in my van
um
the chick that plays the accordion is
called christina mariani check her out
on instagram
send me chinese brides
i'm gonna see joe rogan tonight i'm
opening up for him at the vulcan tonight
so hope to see you there
uh this is a apartment
that i'm in
this is live
uh hence the little live logo
uh so
yeah i mean i'm coming to a close i
actually want to be entertaining uh
i think that it's great that you laugh a
lot at rogan i don't think rogan is like
a laugh out loud podcast i think that
rogan's podcast is very informational
and very logical and very
step and i think that's beautiful and i
think that most conversations are
[ __ ] and when you're just trying to
be funny it's not
that logical and if you're just trying
to be logical it's not that funny so
everyone has a different mix do you ever
discuss political idealistic views with
joe rogan would love to be a fly on the
wall uh by discuss political views i'm
do you mean let him talk
and me just listen because yeah i do
that all the time
florida novax no max
masks regeneron best cover numbers y i
actually don't think florida has the
best cove in numbers
especially if you look at globally i
think we have one of the worst covered
numbers because we refuse to do anything
to stop it we won't wear a mask we won't
get vaccinated we want social distance
like if you're not going to do that what
are you going to do
you're going to what
we're not we're not doing anything to
stop the pandemic and it's spreading and
it's not good we're just hoping that
it's not going to kill us but it's
really not up to us hopefully the the
virus is nice
and that's the only way this thing will
end if the virus chooses to
um uh where is it no one listens they
only talk
um i thought the last podcast was fun um
i thought it was fun to have all those
people over and to shoot the [ __ ] uh
and i had a good time and i want to do
it again i wish that they did interrupt
me so much i feel like they interrupted
me a little bit but maybe i'm just being
egotistical
um
[Music]
take dayquil
i'm not tired uh this is just how i talk
this is how i am i'm very low energy
uh and i'm proud of it i'm not just
gonna talk really fast and really loud
like a
child
child show host
uh
i don't really play that many other
board games
let me sit over on twitch i'm working on
something amazing to send you awesome
hans any funny xanax stories
i'm glad that people like the hangout
podcast because while we're doing it
everyone was like this sucks
this is boring
you guys have too much dead air and then
on reddit they were like
i guess this sucks i guess we gotta go
through the sucky
but i thought it was really fun and i
think that it's fun to hang out with
people and it's an art form and
if i can film it then it'd be awesome to
do it uh so i think it's really cool to
do it
um
conspiracy theorists are giving a lot of
good advice
all right i i'm gonna call it a day i
hope to do this tonight it was fun to do
this for now
for an hour uh i hope you guys enjoyed
it i had a lot of fun doing it
um
because uh it helps me think out loud
and think on my feed and
i think it's good for me so i'm gonna
keep doing it um and i'm gonna have a
good time doing it because it's just me
if i
i'm not having a good time it's really
on me so i love doing it i get to talk
twice as much as i do on any other
podcast since it's only me
and i get better twice as fast so it's
just cool
um but
i uh i hope to kiss more chicks and i
hope to do more fun things like
talk about buttholes or whatever
dogecoin
talk about how i'm not high talk about
how i'm not sleepy talk about how slow i
am and how stupid i sound and how
i'm
like comatose and not really
entertaining and i don't have energy i'd
love to talk more about it i love to
talk more about you know kyle
rittenhouse and everything
that pisses other people off
let's see
how much
we can
piss people off and still have an
audience
um and i love science talk and all that
uh thank you good night